so did senator manchin break his
commitment to you
senator manch and i are going to get
something done thank you
president biden trying to put his best
foot forward on healing the rift with
senator joe manchin after the white
house called him a liar but radical
democrats don't want to hear it
progressives are focused on pressuring
biden to go it alone on the spending
plan aoc tweeting this biden needs to
lean on his executive authority now he
has been delaying and under utilizing it
so far jesse the same people who whinge
and screech about the ruination of
democracy
um are telling him to trample on the
constitution yeah let's make him king
we'll build him a throne put a crown on
his head we'll just have a monarchy
squad can go home we don't need congress
power the purse give it to joe
get send the supreme court home too
while we're at it right no checks and
balances we're just a monarchy now that
like who talks like that it doesn't even
pass the if the shoe were on the other
foot test which is a great test and you
know how much i hate tests
this is like did you pass that yes the
only one is if
trump were president and he didn't have
a majority in the senate you think aoc
would be like yeah just let trump enact
the maga agenda but no of course she
wouldn't this just shows the mentality
of the far left don't renegotiate this
thing you know don't try to persuade
anybody go don't go back to the drawing
board just jam it through just jam it
right through
these instincts are crazy this is a
crazy kind of instinct
greg uh bette midler is the new
spokesbroad for the squad clearly or
she's auditioning for that job
poor illiterate and strung out on drugs
is how she described west virginians and
then kind of sort of apologized which
clearly somebody told her to do that i
mean you've got to be strung out to
watch one of her movies i mean have you
ever seen beaches no don't go there uh
you like cages yeah i don't do oh it's a
terrible film uh you know it's really
funny when you see kind of clearly
washed up people on twitter because
they've had a great career and all it
takes is a few tweets to kind of unravel
a fan base because there are people in
west virginia that probably do like
bette midler three or four the media
response to all of this is interesting
because they're like a down and out
gambler right who put everything on red
at the russian at the roulette table and
then it went black uh this i mean
they're absolutely devastated i've never
seen so many people upset over something
they didn't read with the exception of
the bible
a little religious food for thought yeah
for today and by the way
i put my hand in your shot greg i
apologize you know that's we're gonna
have to talk about that i was doing my
wind beneath my wings
i mean it's a good story i don't
necessarily like her as an individual
but it's a good story no no no she's
dreadful uh but west virginians
back mansion listen to this danny i want
your reaction
i support joe mansion 120
for him um not backing down to
biden because west virginia suffered for
biden's choices absolutely supportive
nothing in that bill was going to help
west virginia i think it was the right
thing to do
and they're wearing masks in west
virginia aoc wow wow
i think the condescension from
the left about west virginians is
something that's been on display but
also they're really not very smart on
politics joe manchin knows his state and
he's not there to represent the left
he's there to represent his state and a
state was saying no and so i think
there's uh
obviously some rethinking that needs to
be done like a bernie sanders who says
well i'm going to go into west virginia
and tell them how wrong they are they
they will not listen to him the last
thing i would say on this uh do you know
give a mouse give a mouse a cookie yeah
that book this is like the policy
version of it if you give a massive
cookie he's going to want 10 more if you
give them a if you give liberals a
mandate for something they'll take 10
more if you give them a tax hike they'll
come for all of your uh income and
that's what they're trying to do is
build back better it's like no no we
were going to take that and then we're
going to get even more
so
that's what give them an energy
should you what if you just teach the
mouse to fish yeah i think it's if you
lead a horse to water then you teach the
horse to fish don't you know the book if
you give them out there you can lead a
horse in the water we haven't read that
one this is waters please
text your son please do not talk
directly to my mother
don't look at gift mouse
don't look at gift mouse in the tail
because it stinks
you
help
like fish
i will say that i also have three kids
and i haven't read that book but i mean
i get the analogy i know where she's
going with this and she's right you they
they tend to do that you give them one
thing and they ask for more and more
more that's what the buildback better
was all about manchin was concerned
about social security and medicare and
things that are already running out of
funding funding and he is looking out
for the people that he represents and
that's the bottom line does manchin like
the movie beaches though
yeah i mean he should we need to know
this i'm gonna look up how many copies
of if you give a mouse a cookie have
been sold why would you give a mouse a
cookie when it's clearly they like
cheese this seems very like a strange
book were you in a cult growing up a
little bit yep
[Laughter]
library cult
not a member
next what the
cursing is through the roof experts know
exactly what's to blame
[Music]